netflix had a tough first quarter it
reported the
first drop in subscribers in almost a
decade look at this chart we can see how
the number of subscribers grew and grew
and grew and then in this quarter it
dropped by 200 000
they expect it to drop by further 2
million in the upcoming quarter now why
is that it's partly to do with the end
of lockdowns people not having as much
time to spend in front of screens it's
partly to do with inflation with uh not
as much discretionary spending therefore
people cutting back on their netflix it
also has something to do with russia
where netflix has pulled out of but it
does have implications for the streaming
industry as a whole look at this chart
it's the price to earnings ratio for
netflix disney and paramount at the top
line the white one for netflix you can
see it used to traded a massive premium
to those other companies now disney
around the end of 2020
pivoted towards the netflix model it's
going to double down on disney plus
focus on being a growth stock that means
investors value it based on how big they
think it's going to be at some stage in
the future
but if you are a growth stop and growth
slows you get punished by investors and
so you can see here the white line of
netflix crossing below
disney as a valuation multiple
now what can netflix do to reignite
growth it basically has three tools it
can try to add more subscribers that's
clearly a struggle at the moment it can
increase prices also maybe a little bit
difficult given the inflationary context
the third thing and that's what it is
doing it is talking about advertising
and introducing an advertising funded
tier now the advantage of advertising is
it might only cost the user a few
dollars but the upside of what you can
make from advertisers themselves is
almost limitless you think about
facebook which makes something like 130
a year
from advertisers per user in the us
that's the growth strategy now for
netflix as it really struggles to add
new subs
you